common sense gun legislation common
sense policy about guns common sense gun
reforms we have to act
we can't wait take the firearms first
and then go to court i don't need to
wait another minute to take common sense
steps
after reaching historic lows in the
mid-2010s gun violence rates in america
have gone up in recent years and they
remain higher than in some other parts
of the developed world there are
hundreds of laws and regulations that
restrict americans access to firearms
yet according to some advocates social
science research shows that a few more
simple common sense laws could make a
significant difference the notion that
gun laws don't work it's not borne out
by the evidence and evidence and data is
in
gun safety saves lives it's not
something we assert something we can
prove over and over and over again
that's not even
in dispute of the thousands of studies
that have been done on the effect of gun
control laws
nearly all are so flawed as to be total
nonsense
100 or so good studies are usually
ignored or misrepresented by politicians
in the media statistician aaron brown
has taught at nyu and the university of
california at san diego he's a columnist
for bloomberg and a leading expert on
risk management if you think most
published journal articles on public
policy issues have clear causal
conclusions such as that a specific gun
control regulation does or does not work
you would be mistaken federal gun crime
prosecutions are up 16 percent since i
took office but we must do more and i
think there needs to be vigorous
prosecution of gun laws on the books
last year
we prosecuted a record number of
firearms offenses gun control policies
based on flawed research can have
tremendous costs they turn otherwise
law-abiding citizens into criminals and
they increase prosecutorial power and
mass incarceration they exacerbate the
racial and socio-economic inequities in
the criminal justice system brown points
to a 2020 meta-analysis from the
non-partisan research organization the
rand corporation that analyzed 27 900
studies on the effectiveness of gun
control regulations
the authors concluded that 0.4 percent
were only 123 were rigorous enough to
provide meaningful results and even
among those many didn't answer the most
pressing question for policymakers do
gun control laws reduce violence 123
studies that met the rand criteria were
the best of the bunch but they still had
serious defects in fact given the
uncertainties in the data it's next to
impossible for any study to prove that a
particular gun control measure had any
effect whatsoever the only thing we can
say confidently is many of the most
widely trumpeted results are likely
based on random chance alone
peer-reviewed journals generally accept
a result as statistically significant if
it has a 1 in 20 chance or less of being
due to random chance this means that if
researchers run 100 studies on the
relationship between two things that
obviously have no connection to each
other at all say milk consumption and
car crashes by pure chance they can be
expected to get five statistically
significant results that are entirely
coincidental such as that milk drinkers
get into more accidents so what was
wrong with the 123 studies that met the
approval of the rand researchers these
papers tested 722 separate hypotheses
about the impact of gun control laws at
the 5 percent level of significance even
if there were no relationship between
gun laws and violence much like the
relationship between drinking milk and
getting into car accidents we'd expect
about five percent of those 722 tests or
36 results to show that gun regulations
had a significant impact collectively
these papers found significant results
for only 18 combinations of gun control
measure and outcome
half would we would expect by random
chance if gun control measures had no
effect at all
but let's assume that these 18
statistically significant results were
not the result of random chance and do
demonstrate a relationship between gun
laws and violence are there any
meaningful takeaways brown argues that
these findings actually have very little
relevance for policy makers because of
the poor quality of the data researchers
often conceal this by using the shoddy
data to build conceptual models and then
claiming high confidence in the results
the models spit out in reality gun
violence is rare enough that it's nearly
impossible for researchers to figure out
what difference a law makes if any
for example one of the significant
results cited by rand found that more
restrictive child access laws could stop
a total of two kids across 11 states
from injuring themselves each year with
a gun these events are simply too rare
to get meaningful statistical estimates
there's simply too much variation from
other factors and random noise to give
any precise estimate of this number
brown says similar data issues plagued
most social science research that tries
to tease out the effects of a policy
change on rare events like accidents
suicides or homicides these studies are
doomed from the start regulations can
take years to implement and enforce
and will likely affect only a small
fraction of new gun sales
new gun sales are a small fraction of
all total firearms owned
therefore the most optimistic projection
of first year effect of a gun control
rule would be a small fraction of one
percent of gun homicides but gun
homicide rates in states change by an
average of six percent in years with no
legislative changes fatal data problems
like this frustrate all gun control
research that attempts to tease out the
effect of marginal policy changes on
suicides homicides or anything else it
frustrates opponents of gun control who
sometimes argue that guns are more often
used for self-defense than to victimize
others anyone basing a gun control
position on scientific evidence is
building on sand
we have no useful empirical data on the
subject and we have no body of work that
rises above the level of expected false
positives either for or against gun
control according to brown there's
another major takeaway from the rand
analysis the numbers indicate that
researchers are suppressing results that
show gun control policies do nothing or
have the opposite of their intended
effect of the 722 hypotheses contained
in 123 studies that met the approval of
the rand researchers only one
significant result found that a gun
control measure had made gun violence
worse even by random chance those
studies should have yielded about 36
false positive results and roughly half
of them should have shown the opposite
of what researchers expected so why is
it that only one published finding
showed that a gun control measure didn't
work given the vast number of studies
done the vast number of hypotheses
tested we would expect more of these
negative results by random chance alone
the fact that only one was found
suggests strongly researchers are
suppressing negative results the rarity
of pro-gun control results and the near
total absence of anti-gun control
results are strong evidence that we know
nothing about the effect of gun control
regulations
gun control researchers aren't the only
ones guilty of misusing statistics the
studies that get the most attention from
reporters and politicians are the ones
that claim the most shocking and
powerful effects which according to
brown are usually also based on the
flimsiest evidence none of the 123
studies blessed by ran got significant
media or legislative attention it was
the worst studies with the most
outrageous claims from among the 27 000
that rand excluded that made the
headlines hundreds of studies have been
done comparing gun homicide rates before
and after states change their gun
control laws one prominent study made
the astounding claim that a permit
requirement for handgun purchases in
connecticut reduced their gun murder
rate by 40 percent it's common sense you
should need a license to buy and own a
firearm in states like connecticut that
did that they saw 40 drops in gun
violence it is true that connecticut's
gun murder rate fell rapidly after that
law was passed in 1995 but so did gun
murder rates throughout the country in
order to form a conclusion about the
effect of the connecticut law you would
want to compare connecticut to something
as similar as possible that did not make
the change but the authors do not
compare connecticut to itself in prior
years nor to all other states their 40
percent claim is the actual murder rate
in connecticut compared to something
they call a synthetic connecticut that
they constructed for the purpose of
their study a combination of mostly
rhode island but also maryland
california nevada and new hampshire the
paper claims to show a 40 decline in gun
murders in connecticut as compared to
synthetic connecticut but brown says
this entire effect is due to the fact
that rhode island experienced about 20
extra murders between 1999 and 2003 and
synthetic connecticut was more than 72
percent rhode island even comparing to
synthetic connecticut the decline the
authors found didn't last although the
law remained on the books by 2006 the
gun murder rate in connecticut had
surpassed synthetic connecticut
and continued to increase to the point
where it was 46 higher the authors
despite publishing in 2015
elected to ignore data from 2006 and
afterwards
they're making strong claims based on
complex models and uncertain data worse
they cherry pick their time periods and
locations to get their preferred outcome
this is unfortunately common in social
science research on gun control we know
that states with the most gun laws
tend to have the fewest gun deaths what
people in vermont and i suspect new
hampshire understand is that guns in our
part of the world are very different
than guns in chicago los angeles and new
york the real story on gun control is
that states with strong gun control
regulations are different from states
with weaker gun control regulations
they're richer more liberal more urban
and they have lower murder and suicide
rates
the effect is almost certainly the
reverse places with low crime rates are
more willing to give up personal guns
and richer people put more trust in the
police to protect them from crime
but the cultural differences are too big
there's just too much uncertainty about
this to say anything about what would
happen if we enforce greenwich
connecticut laws in festus missouri we
can ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines in this country
once again
i got that done when i was a senator and
it brought down these mass killings then
there's the question of whether bans on
assault style weapons and large capacity
magazines which are often passed
together have reduced the frequency or
deadliness of mass shootings researchers
define basic terms like assault weapons
and mass shootings differently they
limit their data by time place or other
factors such as classifying an event as
an act of terror and therefore not
considering it a mass shooting these
varying definitions make studies apples
to oranges comparison
and they invite researchers to cherry
pick finding limited data sets based on
number of casualties type of weapons
time period and other factors to support
whatever conclusions the researcher
wants the bottom line is the effect of
bans on large capacity magazines or
assault weapons on mass shootings is
inconclusive for the same data problems
that affect all gun control policy
research but there's a further problem
mass shootings are extremely rare
relative to other forms of gun violence
and most of them don't involve assault
weapons
depending on what definitions you use
mass shootings involving assault weapons
are a small fraction of one percent of
all gun homicides in that ten years we
had it done
the number of mass shootings actually
went down and since then
the number of massacres has increased
183 percent mass shootings went up 200
percent in the decade after the assault
weapons ban expired
for example the u.s federal ban on
assault weapons and large capacity
magazines was in place for 10 years from
1994 to 2004.
before during and after which many
societal factors caused crime rates to
vary widely
making it impossible to draw useful
conclusions about the effect of the ban
on anything and in particular on
something as rare as mass shootings this
type of mass violence does not happen in
other advanced countries states and
countries with bans define assault
weapons and other key elements of laws
differently so combined with the data
problems inherent in comparing different
populations of people over different
periods of time
comparisons between states and countries
are almost meaningless
another rand corporation meta-analysis
updated in 2020 found inconclusive
evidence that these bans have any effect
on mass shootings or violent crime but
how about the more straightforward
question of whether owning a gun makes
you more or less safe one widely
influential study that is constantly
resurfaced in headlines since it was
published in the new england journal of
medicine in 1993 concluded that rather
than confer protection guns kept in the
home are associated with an increase in
the risk of homicide by a family member
or intimate acquaintance brown says
there are major problems with this study
first of all the researchers concluded
that keeping a gun at home increases a
person's risk of being killed but nearly
half the murders they included in their
analysis were not committed with a
firearm and among gun owners who were
killed with a gun the authors didn't
establish whether the weapon used was
the victim's own gun or if it belonged
to another person but brown says the
main reason research on this topic is
inconclusive is because the answer
almost entirely depends on individual
differences that can't easily be
controlled for in social science
research a gun expert with a gun safe
and a high crime neighborhood may well
be safer with a gun whereas a careless
alcoholic living in a low crime area who
keeps loaded guns in his kid's closet is
certainly going to be less safe people
want a simple overall answer to whether
guns make you less safe or more safe
in order to inform legislation but
social science cannot deliver that when
the researchers behind the 1993 study
tried to control for all the variation
between people to tease out just the
effect of owning a gun their analysis
found that other factors can increase
your risk of being killed even more than
having a firearm at home what most
present politicians citing the
blockbuster 1993 study leave out is that
although it did find that owning a gun
increased your risk there were other
things that were much more dangerous
including living alone or being a renter
there were no coherent arguments as to
why we wouldn't do this i am open and
ready to listen and discuss all ideas
that will actually work advocates who
feel strongly and are
pushing every day to make the rational
changes
activists may argue that even if the
evidence isn't solid any new restriction
on guns is worth trying in the effort to
reduce violence since there's also no
convincing evidence that gun control
doesn't work after all most laws don't
have firm scientific underpinnings and
it's certainly plausible that general
government discouragement of guns can
reduce violence over long periods of
time but these policies also have
significant costs restricting our
freedoms and causing more people to go
to prison disproportionately from poor
and minority communities and it's not
just gun control
nearly all similar policy analysis
suffers from the same issue too much
complexity for the available data
partisans yearn for scientific backing
for their views but scientists cannot
deliver it
researchers flock to the field because
there's money and interest in results
and they peer review each other's work
without applying the kind of rigor that
would eliminate nearly all publications
we can and will stop this evil contagion
not just the gun crisis
but what is actually a public health
crisis this is an epidemic for god's
sake in the 1990s the nra convinced
congress to cut all of cdc's funding for
gun research but now in a stunning turn
the current director of the cdc is
announcing a plan to reduce gun violence
the director of the cdc rachelle
wolensky declared in august that the
agency would begin treating gun violence
as a public health crisis and congress
approved an initial 25 million dollars
in new funds towards scientific research
on the topic for those who are worried
about research in this area i'm not here
about gun control i'm here about
preventing gun violence and gun death
these are complex issues that require
rigorous scientific investigation to
come to any kind of useful conclusion
and they depend far more on individual
variation as well as broad social and
cultural factors than on any regulation
we should not panic and pass more laws
that sweep up innocent victims while
doing more harm than good all with the
alleged backing of science
that can't possibly tell us what we need
to know